في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها دمرت
اثنتين واربعين طائره مسيره فوق شبه جزيره
القرم في الساعه الاولى من صباح اليوم
ليصل مجموع المسيرات التي دمرتها خلال 24
ساعه في جميع المواقع الى 73 بحسب قولها
يضم الينا من موسكو نور الدين الدغير ومن
اكياذ عامر لافي نور الدين اكثر من 70
مسيره اوكرانيه خلال 24 ساعه كيف تقيم
موسكو زياده وتيره الهجمات بالمسيرات
الاوكرانيه على اراضيها
[تصفيق]
نعم جلال والاهم الاهم بالنسبه للجانب
الروسي هو الحديث عن الهجوم الذي تعرضت له
شبه جزيره القرم باعتبار ان هذا الهجوم
اصبح يصنف الان اكبر هجوم تقوم به القوات
الاوكرانيه على مستوى المسيرات باتجاه شبه
جزيره القرم من اكثر من بين اكثر من 70
مسيره 42 مسيره كان هدفها هو استهداف
مواقع يبدو انها ذات اهميه استراتيجيه
كبرى لدى الجانب الروسي على شبه جزيره
القرم مطارات مواقع دفاعات جويه
مؤسسه طاقه حراريه او مركز طاقه حراريه
بالاضافه الى مركز تدريب اذن الان يبدو ان
العمليه اصبحت عمليه اكثر استراتيجيه في
التعامل ما بين الجانب الاوكراني والجانب
الروسي واصبحت الاهداف الاستراتيجيه هي
النتائج الاساسي اذا هناك اقرار روسي بان
هناك هجوم كبير سنه القوات الاوكرانيه
بمستوى المسيرات على الجانب الروسي وكذلك
هناك اعتراف روسي واضح بانها استعملت
صواريخ متطوره عاليه من البحر باستهداف
مواقع اكثر اهميه اكثر استراتيجيه بالنسبه
لروسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه والحديث
هنا الحديث الروسي على ان الاستهدافات
التي كانت في اوديستان هي استهدافات بحسب
وزاره الدفاع مواقع تشكل تهديدا عسكريا
للقوات الروسيه وحينما يتم الاشاره الى
هذا المصطلح بهذه الطريقه بكل تاكيد هو
المكان الذي تنطلق منه المسيرات او المكان
الذي تجمع فيه المسيرات وتستهدف هذه
المناطق هناك حديث عن استهداف بتروفيسك
الاستهداف هنا تتحدث وزاره الدفاع على انه
استهدف منشاه عسكريه وبالتحديد مكان
للذخيره ومكان للنقل والتوزيع الاستراتيجي
وبالتحديد الحديث عن مكان سكه تنقل
المعدات الاستراتيجيه للجانب الاوكراني
اذا هي حرب ربما اصبحت اكثر نوعيه في
التعامل مع الاطراف سواء من الجانب
الاوكراني الذي يحاول استعمال المسيرات او
من الجانب الروسي الذي يحاول الاستهداف
العمق الاوكراني موا تشكل ربما تهديد اكبر
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي لانها تشكل محل
انطلاق لاستهداف العمق الروسي او استهداف
شبه جزيره القرن لا يمكن ان نغفل هنا عن
اسقاط صاروخ من طراز اس 200 المعدل والذي
استهدف استهدف العمق الروسي كذلك لا يمكن
ان نستهدف المسيرات الذي استهدفت اذا هنا
يبدو انها حرب شامله تنطلق بالنوعيه
والاستراتيجيه وكذلك لتتحول على مستوى
الارض هنا كذلك يجب الحديث على ان الحرب
ليست على مستوى المسيرات فقط ليست على
مستوى الصواريخ لكن يبدو ان قوات المدفعيه
قوات البريه قوات المشاه كذلك تتحرك على
الامتداد من الشمال والشمال الغربي هنا
حديث روسي على ان الجانب الروسي يبدو انه
يحقق نوعا من التقدم العسكري باتجاه
كوبيانس الحديث هنا عن بلدتين في باتجاه
كوبيانكوفكا وبلده اخرى كذلك بالقرب منها
يبدو ان هناك ضغط روسي قوي على هاتين
البلدتين يبدو انها تشكل عمق استراتيجي
باتجاه كومبيونس ويسعى الجانب الروسي
للسيطره عليها لكن الحديث الروسي كذلك
يقول بان الجانب الاوكراني بان الجانب
الاوكراني يحاول يستميت بشده لمنع سقوط
هاتين البلدتين لدى لصالح الجانب الروسي
ونستمع الان الى المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الذي يفصل في طبيعه المعركه ما بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه
البحري الروسي ضربه ناجحه باسلحه عاليه
الدقه وطويله المدى على منشاه للبنيه
التحتيه للموانئ تستخدم لمصلحه القوات
الاوكرانيه اما في محور دونيسك فقد نجحنا
في صد ثلاث هجمات نفذتها القوات
الاوكرانيه وبلغت خسائر العدو في هذا
المحور ما يصل الى 260 عسكريا اوكرانيا
بين قتيل وجريح اما في محور زبالوجيا
فتصدينا لخمس هجمات للعدو كما تم صده هجوم
في محور جنوب دونسك والقضاء على حواليه
125 عسكريا اوكرانيا وهجوم اخر في محور
كراسن ليمن
عامر ماذا نفهم من استراتيجيه المسيرات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه خاصه
القرد
نعم جلال يعني الاوكرانيون تحدثوا في اكثر
من مناسبه اولا بالنسبه للقرن هي وضعها
مختلف لانها هي ارض اوكرانيه محتله كما
يقولون وبالتالي هدف مشروع واستهدافها
بشكل يعني دائم هو هدف استراتيجي اصلا لدى
القوات الاوكرانيه تعلم بالامس اعلنوا عن
انزال بحري وهو الاول من نوعه منذ عام
2014 وكانت مفاجاه وحدث يبدو انه ارادوا
ان يتزامن مع عيد الاستقلال اوكرانيا الذي
تصدف بالامس الرابع والعشرين من اغسطس
وبالتالي الحديث عن القرم وانها جزء لا
يتجزا من الدوله الاوكرانيه هو يعني امر
اصبح يعني شبه يومي نسمعه على لسان
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بالنسبه لاستخدام
المسيرات بشكل عام هو على ما يبدو المخرج
الاوكراني جلال لتعلم الاسلحه الغربيه
التي وصلت الى هنا هناك اشتراك بان لا
تستخدم في الداخل الروسي هذه المسيرات كما
قال الاوكرانيون هي
محلي وبالتالي لا احد يمكنه ان يفرض على
اوكرانيا اين يمكن استخدامه بالتالي كانت
هي مخرج بالنسبه للاوكرانيين لاستخدامه
ولقد مضاجع ان صح التعبير روسيا في مناطق
مهمه لاسيما العاصمه موسكو التي اصبحت
تضرب بشكل يومي بخصوص ما جرى اليوم في
القرن هناك تصريح مهم للمتحدثه باسم
عمليات الجنوب نتاليا ومنيوك التي قالت
بتعليقا على التصريحات الروسيه بانه تم
اسقاط كل هذه المسيرات قالت بخصوص طبعا
شبه جزيره القرم قالت نعم اعترفت بان
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه قويه نعم قالت
قويه لكن قالت بان لدينا حيلنا الخاصه
التي يمكن من خلالها تجاوز هذه الدفاعات
نعم يسقط الكثير من الطائرات لكن هناك
طائرات مسيرات تسقط وتصيب اهدافها في شبه
جزيره القرم وقالت بان هذه التصريحات اي
التصريحات الروسيه هدفها هو مسكين السكان
المحليين وطمانتهم لكن الهجمات مستمره هذا
وفقا لقياده عمليات الجنوب بخصوص طبعا
ربما هناك ايضا شيء لافت ومهم بالنسبه
نتحدث عن الجنوب هو استهداف اوديسا القوات
الروسيه فجر هذا اليوم استهدفت اوديسا
استهدفت اوديسا باربعه صواريخ صاروخان من
البحر الاسود وصاروخ من بحر ازوف وقالت
ايضا المتحدثه باسم عمليات الجنوب نتاليا
ومنيوك بان هذه هي المره الاولى التي تضرب
اوديسا بصواريخ كاليبر لكن قوات الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني تمكن من صدرها وقالت انه
واضح ان هذه هي حيله وتكتيك لتجاوز
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه فلنستمع لمقاله
خلال الليل كانت هناك موجه ثاني من
الهجمات الروسيه على المناطق الجنوبيه في
البدايه اطلقوا صاروخين كروسكاياك 35 في
اتجاه احد موانئ منطقه اوديس دمرت هما قوه
الدفاع الجوي وبعد ساعات قليله هاجم اوديس
بصاروخين من طراز كروس كاليبر من حامله
صواريخ في بحر ازوف وتم تدميرهما ايضا
ولذلك لم تقع اصاباتنا واضرار نتيجه هذا
الهجوم يشير هذا الهجوم الى ان الروس
يحاولون ايجاد تكتكات واتجاهات جديده
للصواريخ لتجاوز انظمه الدفاع الجوي
شكرا لكما عامر فيك كيف ونور الدين في
موسكو